the Nintendo 3ds has enjoyed a long
lifespan and it has a vast library of
amazing game so now is as good a time as
any to hook someone up with this great
handheld if they already have one there
are a few accessories you can get them
as well this is GameSpot's Holiday Gift
Guide for the Nintendo 3ds first things
first if you're gonna get someone a
system consider the new 3ds XL like the
name implies it has a 3d effect that
actually tracks the distance between the
system and your eyes to adjust the 3d
effect properly and make sure you get a
system with the new moniker which means
it has enhanced hardware and extra
buttons which some games require don't
forget that there are also special
editions of the 3ds XL like the Samus
Edition that we have here if you don't
think the 3d effect is important you can
always get the 2d s XL which is a little
bit cheaper and still sports the same
hardware improvements and extra buttons
of the new systems this particular
version I have right here is the
pokeball edition so pokemon fans would
really appreciate this as you can see
the 2d s XL still has the large screens
and has a sleek minimalist design and it
closes up real nicely everyone needs to
keep their 3ds or 2d s XL safe so hook
them up with a carrying case this one in
particular is from Amazon there's
nothing too fancy about the Amazon
basics carrying case but it does strap
in your system quite nicely and it has a
little flap to store some 3ds games like
any game system internal storages of
premium and the 2d s and 3ds XL only
come with a four gigabyte microSD card
so a bigger card will come in handy this
one I have right here is a 32 gigabyte
micro SDHC card from Santis all you have
to do is pop it in and now you could
store all your downloaded games on this
card in addition to looking like cool
figurines that the me bows will actually
grant you in-game bonuses for example
the Samus and the Metroid amiibos will
unlock a game mode artwork and
additional items in Metroid Samus
Returns but a little research will go a
long way so make sure you buy the right
amiibo depending on what they play and
if you're still having trouble looking
for a gift for a 3ds or 2d s owner you
can always hook them up with a Nintendo
eShop card these come in values of $10
$20 $35 and $50 and they act as currency
in
Nintendo's eShop so they can buy
whatever games or add-ons that they want
these are a few of the great gift ideas
for the Nintendo 3ds now all you have to
do is make a decision give your present
and watch the smile on their face as
they open it up for all our holiday gift
guides this season head on over to
GameSpot calm thanks for watching
we'll see you soon
[Music]